who mark griffiths the botanist in his
story and it's saying that he thinks
that this sketch is a portrait of
Shakespeare Donna at the time that he
was still alive what is why does he come
to that conclusion what's his theory
well he has been working on this for
five years incredibly so it's not a soul
flash in the pan thing and he was
actually working on a completely
different project and he was looking at
the frontispiece of this incredible book
about plants and botany by john Gerard
and he and there were four figures in it
which were supposedly allegorical and he
began to work out which each figure was
using a method of ciphers heraldic
motifs and solemn attic flowers and he
worked out who the other three were and
then he was wondering who the fourth man
was and he then worked out using this
incredible cracking this incredible
chudir code it's rather like a mixture
of the davinci code and Bletchley Park
or mixed up and he worked out this the
Studer code and realized amazingly it
was William Shakespeare what do you make
of this up there in stratford-on-avon
hello I do it believe a word of it sorry
I i I'm able to do with flowers and
Latin yes I have yes i have had looked
yes i've looked at the whole thing of
course yes we've got here a figure
addressed in roman costume holding a
fritillary in one hand the corncob in
the other which doesn't particularly
call Shakespeare to mind we have what's
supposed to be a code but one has to ask
first of all why code it anyway you know
why why why we could produce a conundrum
which will not be solved for 415 or so
years it's it just seems beautiful
absurdity that's a does look a bit like
the bloke behind you sorry doesn't
matter what he looks like I did you know
the visual appearance has nothing
whatever to do with it anyhow the bloke
behind me was painted in 1600
in when Shakespeare was 46 years old the
the bloke in that on the title page
can't have been more than 33 if it
shakes because she was born 33 years
before the title page was created it's a
lovely title page the three other
figures are identifiable one as Lord
Burleigh who employed Gerard the other
another as Gerard himself and the other
has the original author of the book the
book is not actually medley by Gerard
it's by a Dutch phone call due do it and
he's the other figure the world in the
top right hand corner so we heard that
Stanley Wells is skeptical about this
he's not he's not the only one is he he
raises the question why would someone
make a cipher a spit made it make a code
out of it and this book's been around
for 400 years so why wouldn't anyone
else make that connection if it is him
well the Elizabethans love to code and
it was and it was used quite a lot this
this technique it was it was a bit of
fun and and the other figures are sort
of coded I mean law burly is there but
he's actually dressed up as Solomon and
at the time if you were living at the
time you would have work he was referred
to a lot of Solomon and you would have
begun to work it out I mean are there
any connections between the other
characters are responsible for the book
and Lord Burleigh and Shakespeare well
that's the fascinating thing because we
haven't just discovered an image here we
have discovered a whole series of
connections which I think could
completely change the way we look at
Shakespeare yes there's no one quite
realize maybe in libraries his was his
patron in this to the story as well so
you not convinced still no but but how
well you've got no evidence Lee was the
patron you're just created you're just
inventing that yourself whatever even if
we took it is to be Shakespeare there's
no evidence that it was that he was that
shakes me with a burly was paid for and
that's just invention well good well
what you'll see them tomorrow in country
life because the magazine comes out
tomorrow morning it's 19 pages that mark
is the man whose discover this will
explain all the early absolute deep and
Accord very much to really I think you
will be amazed understand next week and
the next week next week you've got a new
play by Shakespeare too haven't you
you've got all the luck haven't eat it
it is a new media pay but we didn't want
it to undo door do it all at once so
yeah well at least you both are like
that stand there and that wouldn't be
good that wouldn't be that all right
message we can add got a point agree at
least you are both agreed Shakespeare's
stratford-on-avon was the author of the
plays no no dispute on that oh
absolutely sweet at all and I think I
hear their firm that he's the author of
all the place and Stanley Wales finally
however this doesn't confirm anything
how often do you have in general
tourists how often do you have new
claims about portraits being discovered
belongings manuscripts and how common an
occurrence is it oh they're rather
they're quite oh they're pretty frequent
people are always hoping of course to
make new discoveries about chicks and
sometimes they do when I first heard
about this I thought how interesting
perhaps we're going to have a new
genuine Shakespeare document a new
Shakespeare signature things can turn up
I'm not skeptical at all about the
possibility of discovering be made but
I'm totally unconvinced that this is a
discovery about chicks we're at all
anyway 19 pages of country life to get
get through tomorrow yard you are
convinced though you because you're not
the author of this I'm not the author of
it but I'm absolutely convinced having
work with mark griffiths the author over
several months of us alright fascinating
South thank you both very much indeed